وفادت وكالته وينها بالكوريه الجنوبيه
بعقد قمه بين الرئيس
الكوري الجنوبيه
اليوم نقلت الوكاله عن الرئيس الكوريه
الجنوبيه شدد على نزع السلاح النووي للشبه
جزيره الكوريه واعتبر ذلك شرطا مسبقا
للسلام في منطقه المحيطين الهندي
ستظل مستعده لتقديم اقصى مساعده اذا قررت
كوريا الشماليه نزع السلاح النووي ومن جهه
ثانيه قالت الانباء اليابانيه ان تهديدات
ساتصدر قمه اليابان والولايات المتحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه اليوم
واكد الرئيس الامريكي
بمنطقه المحيطين الهندي الهادئ مع وجود
ياسين في مركز الاهتمام في بيان للبيت
الابيض عقب قيمته بيضا على اهميه الحفاظ
على السلامه والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان
وشدد على احترام حريه الملاحه والتحليق في
بحر الشرقي وجنوب الصين وضروره حل كل
النزاعات السلميه وقال البيت الابيض ان
الرئيس اثار مخاوف بشان التهديدات التي
تشكلها كوريه الشماليه وادانا بشده من
الحرب التي وصفها بالوحشيه والظالمه التي
تشنها روسيا على اوكرانيا على حد تعبيره
كما عبر بيضا عن القلق بشان الازمه
المتدهوره في
مصلتها الضوء على اهميه اتخاذ الاجراءات
اهو مزيد من الاجراءات والافراج عن
السجناء السياسيين وتوفير العوده الى مسار
الديمقراطيه